the Joe Rogan experience the last movie
Chris Farley ever did was dirty work
Tamino and after it right after dirty
work right before he passed away he
hosted siren in life so normal saloon
Weekend Update so no one caught me up
and said listen Farley's out of control
with coke come to the party after the
show cuz I got you gotta help me watch
him like that's how bad he was I thought
you had to help one so this is this is
our first norm as though this is a
testament to norms wins so I'm at the
party and norms talking to somebody and
I'm watching Chris I'm on coke I'm coked
up so so so I see Farley disappear into
a bathroom with Andy Dick oh okay him
and Andy go into a bathroom
yeah they come out five minutes later
like giggling norm comes over me and
goes what's going on with Chris I go bad
news bro he goes want to go he went to a
bathroom with Andy Dick I said there's
only two reasons a man goes into a
bathroom with Andy Dick and neither one
of them's good and looked at me without
missing a beat and said holy [ __ ] I hope
he's high holy [ __ ] I hope he's high oh
good news uh Chris probably showed up on
a set of news radio one day to visit
Andy yeah sure he did he had the
complexion of wet cardboard I've never
seen a man look [ __ ] hell to do it I
went to a strip club with him at Toronto
he shot there we'll get the rod three
had chicks hanging out I mean he was
just like oh yeah it was took a picture
of him foam coming out of his mouth
laying on the ground yeah that's the
people you're around exactly exactly
yeah it's like
[Applause]